at the beginning she gave me things  perfect balance perfect sleep she wants  to get inside of me I can feel her she  can see me  [Music]  when you dance the dance of another you  make yourself in the image of its  creator I feel like I'm not even here  you dumped likes incredible the way she  transmits her work you have to decide  what is it you want to be for this  company there's more in that building  than what you can see doctor  you are living there's dangerous people  three mothers play God the tavern  Mazatec Navarro Maserati Marvel mothers  Billy all darkness inside you making  some kind of deal with them  [Music]  Oh  the one that's coming  [Music]  you